[Music]
the anaconda is the world's largest
snake and among the most deadly an
anaconda can swallow whole an animal the
size of an average dog
it kills by wrapping itself around its
prey tightening its grip until its
victim can no longer breathe
herpetologist paces rebus studies these
fearsome creatures for a living most of
the time he manages to escape their
wrath but today his luck runs out unable
to escape the Anaconda Strikes Back it
sinks its fangs deep into a Seuss's
flesh his survival depends on extricate
in his hand
what would you do in this situation
should you pull your hands straight out
at the snake's mouth push your hand
further down the snakes throat or put
the snake in the eyes the answer is B
push your hand further down the snakes
throat poking it in the eyes won't make
it let go
more likely a good poke will only make
it dive into the water taking you with
it pulling your hand straight out of the
snake's mouth actually pushes the teeth
deeper into the flesh
that's because anacondas teeth bend
backwards
to safely extract yourself from the
Anaconda you have to actually push
deeper into the mouth and off the teeth
and that's how you survive an anaconda
bite